in 2019 Alexis Ohanian the co-founder
and former executive chairman of Reddit
was watching the Women's World Cup with
his wife Serena Williams when he made a
comment about their daughter playing for
the team Serena said Not until they pay
her what she's worth from that moment
Alexis made it his mission to close the
pay Gap in women's sports he started by
investing in Los Angeles's nwsl team
Angel City we spoke with him and giant
spoon marketing executive Laura correnti
about the true business value of women's
sports
look at the numbers in the business of
women's sports in this moment in time
you see the NCAA you know National
Championship women's basketball you know
9.9 million viewers peaking at 12.6 you
know it's not that we're having a moment
like it is the moment and when you look
at those types of numbers in terms of
fan engagement fan consumption fan
attention and then you look at the
commercial side these things aren't
adding up right you've got one percent
of total sponsorship dollars going to
women's sports you've got less than five
percent of media coverage allocated to
women's sports we need to close this Gap
what do you think is the biggest problem
that can be solved right now it's the
curse of low expectations it's striking
especially in the context of a precedent
that we already have in plain view we're
here in New York City Home of I think
the most important tennis tournament on
the tour the U.S open a sport that when
the U.S open shows up Americans tune in
disproportionately to watch the women
now you start looking across the board
the reason in 2019 I started tweeting
about women's soccer being so
undervalued was because I realized if
you asked me think of American soccer
greatness
I couldn't think of a man because there
hasn't been but I could think of a lot
of women Chastain with that penalty kick
taking off her shirt screaming everyone
being thrilled me a ham in OG and then
in this newer generation in 2019 when I
was mouthing off a team sold for three
or four million dollars that same team
had Megan rapino on it Megan rapino is
worth at least that much in Revenue a
year on her marketing prowess alone so
you don't have to be the smartest person
in the room to say okay someone is doing
a terrible job running the businesses of
these clubs when you have individual
players who in spite of all of those low
expectations in marketing and promotion
Etc still rise Beyond nil has been such
a tremendous win and will continue to be
because you have women who are making
millions of dollars a year in these
brand deals in college who are now going
to create this very uncomfortable
situation because the free market has
dictate did that their influence is
worth millions of dollars a year to
Brands not because it feels good because
it makes them money and so when they
become Pros
you got to look around and say well what
the hell are these clubs doing what the
hell these organizations doing to not
also put the same kind of dollars into
salaries and into investment when we
look back on the legacy of under
investment in women's sports over the
last couple years it will not just be a
legacy of sexism and racism which it is
it'll be a legacy of gross business
incompetence you know you talked about
the NCAA you talk about tennis Olympics
these are events that have huge women
Stars people tune in to the women more
than the men or equal but these are
events that happen at the same time do
you think there's any reasoning behind
that I don't think it's necessarily an
issue of Seasons or Sports overlapping I
think one of the most consistent I
should say themes Alexis and I have
heard in this journey and meeting with a
lot of people in the business and sports
communities is more is more more
visibility more Prime Time not having to
go through paywall on paywall on paywall
to access games that's only going to
help the sports grow and and so I think
the metrics for Success have to be
reevaluated and look at it for what it
is today knowing that with the
visibility of the coverage the
amplification we will get to a place
where the comparison is then at parity
those stories are already there and just
have needed that Spotlight and that's
why this momentum is going to keep
building and that's why I saved the
tweets of every single person who told
me I was going to lose all my money by
starting a women's soccer club you're
going to see this momentum continue and
I I feel so lucky to just have gotten a
surfboard at the right time to get on
this wave because of all the things I've
been early and right into this is the
one that feels so much bigger feels like
a seismic shift of support Angel City
was bought for
to five million dollars and our
expansion fee I can't even tell you how
low the expansion fee was but it was
lower than that but now the the Bay Area
Bay Area has just signed their team for
53 million dollars tenfold of what Angel
City pretty much paid right more does
that make you is that like a sigh of
relief when you're like no I was right I
think for a lot of people who were here
way before me
it's more of a it's an about damn time
and and I that that is not lost on me
right I know I am a a guest in this
world but I'm one who who wants to just
keep playing the role they need to play
right and so no one feels in any way
um relieved everyone feels like yeah
it's about damn time angels city is on
this wave of one to be the first billion
dollar women's franchise how do you get
there you build a rabid dogged fan base
all over the world you continue to raise
the bar on brand Partnerships you
continue to demonstrate the value women
sports fans are such amazing supporters
because they'll buy into the brands that
are partnered with the clubs right right
I mean there's real value there I think
women's sports is at this moment where
the idea of being a sports and
entertainment brand is where I think the
future of women's sports is moving and
once you get to that unlock the
storytelling the game day experience the
community involvement looking at
everything from merch collabs to social
media assets when you start building out
that ecosystem you're no longer just
talking about an on-field product but
really the off-field product the
incomparable I think you're in a whole
different ball game evaluation Alexis
Laura thanks so much for being here I
really appreciate it there's so much
more we could talk about but thanks for
having us thank you
foreign